- If you're wondering what
the most ironic job you
could have while
fasting for Ramadan is
it's probably delivering food.
I work for one of these apps.
It's a nightmare.
Every delivery's like
the worst porn ever.
The delivery guy shows
up to the MILF's mansion,
she answers the door
and then she just takes the
food and shuts the door.
By the way if you
order vegan food
delivered to your
house at rush hour ...
(horn honks)
Sorry.
It's not vegan because
an animal suffered
bringing it to you.
- Hey, Ahamed.
Ahamed.
You're food's ready.
Boy, you better eat somethin'.
- I can't it's Ramadan.
- How're you delivering
food during Ramadan?
- Because of God, I think.
- Well, we're gonna
have sex one day.
It's gonna be so awkward.
I'm a babe.
You're a Jewish Muslim
ass in pork juice
and then I'm gonna wrap
you in a corn tortilla.
- Okay. Bye Punky
- Bye baby.
- Thank you.
Awe Mr. Trump, thank
you for joining us.
- [Speakerphone Voice]
Listen I don't hate Muslims.
I love Muslims.
I went to Muslim.
I met the king.
I saw his castle.
Beautiful castle.
- Interesting you like Muslims.
That's different than what you
said on the campaign trail.
Do you care to comment
on the Muslim ban?
- [Speakerphone Voice]
I never said Muslim ban.
I said I wanted to
start a Muslim band.
Okay.
Muslim band called Allah carte.
I would play the hooka.
- See, no you blamed Islam
for radical Islamic terrorism
which is the same thing as
blaming every sperm in your
dad's ball sack for how
stupid you turned out.
Do you care to comment on that?
Mr. Trump?
We lost him.
Donald! President Donald!
President Donald!
(horn honks)
Sorry.
I can eat in one hour.